well I know You Know Who I am hey Miley
Cyrus we know that growing up as a child
star is hard you totally wanted to be
yourself but Disney Channel executives
didn't want to let you we are glad
you're owning your true self these days
but some of the things you did when you
were a Disney Channel star were totally
wild but you're not alone a lot of your
other co-stars too equally crazy things
you said it yourself nobody's perfect
Disney Channel likes to maintain a
certain family-friendly image but
sometimes their stars make that
difficult keep watching to find out
about Miley's most embarrassing moments
that made Disney Channel freak-outs
bella thorne you might find it strange
that Disney Channel cares about what
their stars wear to the beach but do
they totally do Bella Thorne is a
perfect example of this when she was
still working for Disney Channel she was
photographed at the beach she was
wearing a lacy black bikini that her mom
had bought for her apparently the
swimsuit was so revealing that the
Disney Channel threatened to fire her it
was her only warning if she had messed
up again she would have gotten the boot
how stupid of me
debby ryan we can totally understand why
Disney would be upset with Debbie Ryan
drinking and driving is never cool it
endangers everyone on the road but the
star of Jessi was busted for driving
under the influence in June of 2016
she pleaded guilty and received three
years of probation she tweeted out a
public apology Debbie really seems to
have learned her lesson she is trying to
be a much better role model these days
Vanessa Hudgens Vanessa Hudgens became a
huge star after the release of High
School Musical in 2007 she and Zac Efron
were often in the spotlight for their
relationship but then something terrible
happened shortly after the release of
the first movie Vanessa's email was
hacked
someone found some very private photos
that she had sent to Zach they released
them on the Internet poor Vanessa that's
such an invasion of privacy
Disney kept her on lockdown while they
did damage control Joe Jonas Disney
definitely wants you to think that all
their stars are BFFs
that doesn't mean that they want you to
know what these stars do in their free
time together Joe Jonas completely
ruined that image for Disney Channel he
revealed that the first time he smoked
was with Miley Cyrus and Demi Lovato
keep in mind that what he smoked was
still illegal in California when it
happened and he says he was either 17 or
18 years old
not cool Jo that stuff can mess with a
teenager's brain adam hicks disney's
pair of kings was full of drama after
they fired mitchel Musso for a DUI they
hired Adam Hicks but after his time as
king Boz Adam went off the deep end he
was arrested in 2017 for discharging a
firearm two months later he was arrested
for assault and battery
then in 2018 he his girlfriend were
arrested for three armed robberies we
have to wonder what happened to Adam to
make him turn to a life of crime
Demi Lovato sometimes stars have
scandals after they leave the Disney
Channel but Demi Lovato's huge scandal
happened while she was on tour for camp
rock - she went up to one of her backup
dancers while they were on a private
plane and punched the dancer right in
the face it was all over the news Disney
Channel had to do a lot of damage
control and Demi checked herself into
rehab for substance abuse we hope she's
doing better these days Zac Efron Zac
Efron might be one of the most
successful Disney Channel stars ever but
even he isn't free of embarrassing
moments thankfully Zack had already
moved on from working for the Disney
Channel because they would have been
furious with him at the red-carpet
premiere for the Lorax a certain small
package fell out of Zacks pocket we're
glad he was thinking about safety but
that was not a family-friendly moment no
thanks to you he says he always checks
his pockets now Hilary Duff and Lindsay
Lohan love triangles may make great
storylines and TV shows and movies but
in real life they can be a source of
scandal back in the early 2000s pop
singer Aaron Carter dated to Disney
Channel stars at the same time he dated
Hilary Duff first after meeting on the
set of Lizzie McGuire but then he
started dating Lindsay Lohan him
and Lindsay stops dating Aaron but they
were in a huge feud for years
Disney wasn't a huge fan of this drama
Selena Gomez it's hard to maintain the
good girl image that Disney Channel
expects a lot of stars try to create a
new Wild image after their contracts are
up Selena Gomez starred in the r-rated
movie Spring Breakers as soon as she was
finished with Wizards of Waverly Place
we're not gonna lose we're gonna own it
she starred alongside Vanessa Hudgens
another Disney Channel alum the racy
film was released the same day that a
Wizards TV special aired this was not
quite the image that Disney wanted for
their teenage wizard Miley Cyrus Miley
Cyrus saying nobody's perfect when she
played Hannah Montana and she reminded
her fans that she isn't perfect after a
video went viral she was still working
for the Disney Channel when a video
dropped of Miley smoking although what
she was smoking isn't illegal in
California it is still not a healthy
thing to do for a teen she released a
public apology Disney Channel had
multiple scandals involving Miley Cyrus
but she was too popular to fire Hannah
Montana ended that same year which of
these scandals was the most shocking
tell us your thoughts in the comments
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]